we got this from Scott Galloway he said
Republicans of one-fourth Republicans
think all drag shows should be banned
living in another Century question mark
are you referring to yourself sir I
don't know what or another dimension I
am not surprised that there are Court of
Republicans saying no drag shows that
surprises me in no way I don't what is
it referring to the 90s or something
what other Century but let me show you
how crazy this poll is so here's what it
says who should be allowed to attend
drag shows the purple says they should
be allowed for everyone the blue is
restricted to people 18 and older and
there's not sure and then for orange
they should be banned among all U.S
adult citizens 25 percent say children
should be allowed to attend 50 say 18
and up only 12 are not sure and 14 say
ban it all
now among Democrats around 40 percent of
Democrats think children should be
allowed to attend sex shows
that's what it is drag is basically LGBT
burlesque you wouldn't put a kid you
wouldn't bring kid to a go-go dancer
Club you wouldn't bring your kid to a
burlesque show that's what they're
saying however 40 percent of Democrats
because 39 whose H would be should have
kids four percent Democrats say eight
and up only this is the popular position
yeah in fact eight percent of Democrats
want it banned for everyone okay let me
stress that again eight percent of
Democrats are like no drag shows allowed
for anyone who are those Democrats I
gotta ask you I was gonna say like where
are they that's like a magical unicorn
of a person I guess what like Old Blue
Dog Democrats that still believe in gun
rights and then you have among
Independents it reflects basically what
you see among all U.S adults 26 say kids
should be allowed to attend sex shows 52
think it should be 18 and up and nine
percent say that it should be banned out
right and among Republicans this one is
also the Unicorn this has got to be the
margin of error eight percent of
Republicans think children should be
allowed to attend sex shows 58
Republicans say 18 and up only 25
percent of Republicans say banned
outright look at that divide
nearly four four in ten Democrats think
children should be allowed to attend sex
shows if that persists I just kind of
think Democrats probably won't be a
political party for a lot longer because
they're at odds with the general public
to a great degree
and independent voters I think regular
people you show them what's going on in
these videos then first of all they
don't believe it
I was talking to people about that video
of the guy pulling the baloney out of
his crotch or the zipper and the gay men
thrusting into each other I was talking
to a friend and I was like yeah but look
we're not talking about like just
someone in a costume reading a book
we're talking about children having a
dude in a thong perform like a
striptease dance or uh like on Bill
Maher when it was um Winsome Sears from
Virginia lieutenant governor saying like
look it's about what parents want their
kids to be involved like be or not be
involved in she's like I don't want my
kid getting a lap dance from a drag
queen and then Bill Mark goes well okay
they're reading books I don't think
they're giving lap dances he goes yes
they are he's like well I must have
missed this and she goes bill you need
to read you need to read more yeah and
then everyone laughs because Bill Maher
doesn't read the news you show that to
the average person like you were saying
about sanity and they're going to be
like well I didn't know I was supporting
that yeah in North Carolina a drag queen
gave a lap dance to a child
and and we got you know Ian bought the
book genderqueer not even conservatives
are reading that book and they really
should that's funny conservatives are
like I've seen enough I know it's bad oh
you don't even know the half of it you
should read it
so I think regular people are probably
going to see this and just if we can
show them they're going to be like yeah
I'm out and the hard part is then
getting them out of their algorithm
because their algorithm is only going to
show them what they want to be seeing so
they're not going to be seeing any of
that content on their social media
platforms or anywhere a lot of the
people when I would explain that these
things were going on would be like that
that sounds ridiculous I I don't know if
that's actually nobody believes no they
don't when you tell people what like The
Cutting Edge of leftist thought is
people are like no they all every single
time I tell any average kind of like
Democrat person oh this is what's coming
out of Sociology departments right now
this is The Cutting Edge of leftist out
there like no way no one else you know
no one will believe it no we we really
want to get Bill Maher on this show and
there's been conversations recently
about me going on Bill Maher's show Bill
Maher's going to be in DC in five days
he's doing uh he's doing a stand-up he's
doing stand-up at the MGM National
Harbor
and that's on a Saturday and I'm just
thinking you know a Friday night it's
the perfect opportunity to promote your
show bill should have you on the show no
I'm a big fan of Bill Maher speaking out
against the stuff he's learning about I
just wish with his platform he knew more
and I think it would be one of the most
epic conversations to be sitting here
with him because we have this big these
big monitors and when he's like I don't
know about them giving lap dances like
oh Bill yo Bill let me let me pull the
video up for you and press play and then
we'll just play it right here and he'll
watch it he'll be like okay you're right
you know I always ask the people who are
in support of children being able to go
to drag shows and like oh it's
educational what are they learning are
they learning life skills to get naked
and to work in front of other children
like what is beneficial for a child to
go there it's literally a show that it's
about explicit over-the-top sexual
actions It's Burlesque it's it's like
it's sexualized comedy
it's a clown show I guess the fact that
it's CL it's always sexualized like
there's no drag show that isn't
sexualized so people that make the
argument oh kids really should be able
to get into this I don't I don't I don't
understand how they justify it because
just because the fact that it is clearly
sexualized uh it's they they justified
by saying it's teaching them about
inclusion that it's teaching them that
people with alternative Lifestyles exist
and they're not bad people therefore you
can send your kids to these shows and
it's nothing's gonna happen to them it's
fine it's about inclusion that's
unacceptable because it's unacceptable
to send your kids to Chip and Dales or
to the strip club with the movies I'm
giving you the but to them they don't
think past the first stage of the
argument yeah they're like oh how much
is about inclusion how much do you want
to bet Bill Maher's never seen the video
of the child strippers
that it's not going to lick itself
when when that little boy was ripping
his clothing off on stage and at a gay
bar while they handed money to him I bet
he's never seen it and that one's from
like 2018. yeah like this stuff's been
going on for a long time and the problem
is specifically people like Bill Maher
don't read the news they're like all of
this stuff is happening around the
country and obviously corporate press
covers up I was reading about the
Budweiser uh story in the Washington
Post and they lied about everything
surprise surprise they said the
boycott's not clear there's been any
impact at all and it's like
Anheuser-Busch made it they put out a
commercial and issued a statement
clearly some things got got him worried
and their stock has gone down and
they're like well it's not clear it's
like okay that's that's an argument but
not a news report you can argue since
the controversy started anheuser-bush
stock has dropped by five points or
whatever but they don't they don't
mention that they say and then they said
the whole the whole controversy she
started over a single can of beer a
promo can with Dylan Mulvaney on it and
I was like yeah and the video of Don
Mulvaney drinking Bud Light being a
brand ambassador and dancing and the
estimates that Dylan received 50k or
whatever for doing it I don't know if
that's true or whatever but people are
upset that Budweiser in any way
supported this person it's not about a
single can of beer but they need to lie
diminish and downplay so they can keep
these people trapped in a box and
unfortunately people like Bill Martin
doesn't read the news
the Nike videos were worse those were
actually like looks like he's making fun
of women they all always the the the
Nike ones to me were even more
ridiculous and I always I always really
want to stress this too Dylan Mulvaney
is not trans
like you can't just say like I mean what
if Donald Trump came out right now and
was like my fellow Americans I am now a
woman I am the first female president
Donald Donna Trump and uh they would say
no he's not he's lying right so why look
simply put they would say Donald Trump
is lying he's not trans there's no way
anyone would believe that if Trump came
out as trans anyone would support him
and even if he actually was like legit
was like no I've been hiding this all my
life and he really believed it they
would still say no you're not they would
they would deny forever no matter what
so why should I assume or just give that
benefit of the doubt to someone like
Dylan Mulvaney who I'm gonna say it
again hiking heels putting on high heels
in the forest is not something that
women or trans people do it was a clown
show comedy performance intended to mock
it was literally making fun of women it
was it was an adult male dressing like a
woman claiming to be a girl putting on
high heels and running for the woods and
then getting scared of a bug that is
like the most offensive Woman face
performance you could do you took the
words out of my mouth I was just about
to say this is essentially blackface for
Womanhood and I've seen this clip before
where Dylan was saying how this
initially started as either comedy or
satire I can't remember the exact word
to use but he is known from the
beginning that this was not a serious
thing but he's turned it into a serious
thing because it's become so profitable
and the algorithm on Tick Tock is so
aggressive with it because I don't
follow Dylan I've never liked a single
video of Dylan's I've never saved or
commented on a video of Dylan's but I
will get notifications on my phone from
Tick Tock saying that Dylan Mulvaney
just posted a new video and because and
I have screenshots of it too and because
of that there's going to be an entire
generation of people growing up that are
going to have mental health crisis all
because of Dylan Mulvaney's rice to
stardom this is Elsa gate 2.0 that's why
I describe it as such that the algorithm
just picks things props them up and they
get weirder and crazier so it's it's not
just that it sees what you like and then
makes more of it it's that it doesn't
know what the difference is between what
you like and something with similar
words in it so on YouTube something
interesting happened where if somebody
made a video about immigration YouTube's
algorithm does not know if you're for or
against immigration
all it knows is the title said the word
immigration in it so who does it send it
to people who are for immigration or
against immigration
it doesn't know so with someone like
Donald what happens is there are some
things that people will click thumbs up
on it doesn't know the difference
between Del Mulvaney who's pretending
and mocking and insulting trans people
and say like an actual trans person
making a real argument thus Dylan
Mulvaney's outrageous Shenanigans and
the one big important component is the
incrementation day one day two day three
that creates a a this effect in people
where they need resolution so they
always come back to see the next number
it was perfect algorithmic manipulation
and I think domovany knew exactly what
he was doing and I I will stress it
again we we I've talked to some uh I'm
not going to name the individuals but
we've had the conversation with some of
our uh guests on the show who are trans
who said there's clear signs to them
that Dylan mulvania is not trans based
on the procedures and the things that
Dylan has done
that trans people don't do and or that
trans people would have done and certain
things don't move any does that trans
people would not do there have been
references to I'll give you an example
actually when Don mulvani made the video
and talked about how bulges exist and
women have bulges
what was told to me and maybe this is
just the opinion of a couple trans women
is that
a video like that would cause them
severe anxiety by triggering gender
dysphoria the idea of making a video and
pointing to your junk and saying look at
my junk like Dylan Mulvaney did is is is
the inverse of what someone with a body
dysmorphic disorder would do think about
a person who's anorexic do you think an
anorexic person would make a video where
they're like look at my roles it's okay
that I have roles I'm so fed I'm so fat
everybody look how fat I am look at this
and pinch themselves no they do the
opposite they're terrified of looking
fat to the point where they starve
themselves to death so if Dylan Mulvaney
actually fit the descriptor as most
people like as somebody with dysmorphia
they wouldn't be making videos where
they sing about having penis a bulge in
their pants it is totally fake there you
go
I never thought about it that way but it
makes sense it's yeah because gender
dysphoria is a mental illness I can't
emphasize that enough so for Dylan to be
so glorifying in it it's problematic but
it also just adds to the culture of
mental illness overall because I've
noticed that anxiety and depression have
become such a trend and even ADHD
there's people who have never been
diagnosed with any of those in their
lives so those are three very real
conditions but now it's like to fit in
you have to have some kind of mental
illness I've even had people brag about
like oh yeah I'm so bipolar haha I'm
like is that funny yeah or leave did
people who say that they have like
numerous personalities who inside
themselves and they're talking about
operating as a system basically oh this
part of my system is whatever whatever
it is literally a trend it's literally
like a tick tock thing and people post
about all the time same thing with
Tourette's tourettes is because yeah
yeah part of it is also like in a
culture now where everyone's looking for
something that makes them special or
unique that's something that they feel
like gives them some type of unique
identifier and it's just been turned in
to a weird thing through social media
you know it used to be that if you
wanted to be famous or known about you
had to do something notable so what
you'd get is you know people turn on the
radio or the TV and they'd see actors
and then people were like oh I want to
be an actor I want to be an actor I've
gone through so much of this too I've
had people hit me up and be like you
know back when I worked at advice when I
was traveling around I had so many
people be like oh I really want to do
what you do oh boy and then once they
actually see what it involves like oh I
don't do that like that's not what I was
talking about I want to be on camera and
famous and I'm like okay well I'm on
camera because I like traveling and
talking to people and learning about
what's going on in these places
I'm not on camera because I want to be
on camera that's like paradoxical it's
like like you get on camera for doing a
thing not just being on camera and so
then sure enough people immediately
abandon the line of work they never want
it in the first place people are just
trying to do whatever they have they can
to get attention I find it I think that
it it's surprising to me that there are
so many people that get behind Dylan as
Dylan uh for Dylan being a trans person
it I really feel like there should be
more people that would just be like that
like that is not a trans person that is
a person just looking to be famous
that's just hopping on the band well I I
the way I described it is like that
we're coming to the point where there's
different kinds of transgender there is
gender dysphoric people who look in the
mirror and feel a disconnect between
their body and their biological sex and
that trigger is depressing depression
and things like that and that is the
traditional view of gender dysphoria or
transgenderism but then you have what's
called AGP and what is it AAP Auto
gynophilia and auto androphilia these
are into individuals like the person who
wrote genderqueer friends with the book
right there it's a biological female who
is aroused at the thought of being male
and so once other people to call them
male because it stimulates them which is
more Kink and fetish stuff but then you
have the third chapter which is Dylan
Mulvaney who is not Trans in any of any
sense Michael I think it was Michael
Mouse who said that he thinks it's a
fetish act like AGP and I'm like no no
no it's different it's like I think Leah
Thomas the end uh that was a NCAA
swimmer there was an article talking
about how she was talking to them in the
dress
there's a bunch of posts on talking
about what they call Hep which is like
it's a kink it's a fetish it's not
gender dysphoria but Dylan Mulvaney
isn't doing that Dylan Mulvaney isn't
dysphoric as as I referenced with the
video about singing about having a bulge
a person who is dysphoric doesn't want
that so Dylan Mulvaney being proud and
saying it's okay and look at my junk is
like are you just making fun of trans
people you're clearly not dysphoric so
Dylan Mulvaney's version of trans is it
makes me famous and they're promoting
that to kids that's I'll I'll wrap up
that's why I think the Budweiser boycott
is so important because they didn't they
didn't come out and support the LGBT
community they came out and like you
know I describe it as imagine if
Budweiser came out and sponsored a a an
old school Minstrel show of like a bunch
of dudes in blackface being as racist as
possible and I'm like that's basically
what I see with Dylan Mulvaney insulting
and mocking trans people and women at
the same time to an extreme degree and
then Whoopi Goldberg in the view and all
these other institutions coming out and
defending it that's the same thing that
I said to a friend of mine he he'd uh I
made a remark about the Anheuser-Busch
comment and I said you know this means
keep keep flying pressure and uh he
objected to it and I was just like look
Dylan is not a trans person that is
helping trans people in any way the only
thing he's doing is harming people he's
not making any anyone feel bad for field
in any way sympathetic towards uh trans
people whether the gender dysphoric uh
or not and and I don't think that we
should entertain AGP at all like I don't
want to play along with your Kink right
sorry but look at all the pride parade
events where they have like men with dog
masks the whole month should just be
called Kink and and it should that's
what it is when when we had uh uh I
think Destiny Omni liberal when we were
talking about Ron DeSantis and the books
that were being disallowed they say it's
a book ban yeah they're banning porn
yeah and he was like well this looks
like sex education and I'm like dude
that's a butt plug and he's like yeah
and I'm like that's not sex education
that's Kink education yeah that is the
most ridiculous cope that I've ever
heard come out of Destiny ever like the
the the idea that it's acceptable to
teach people under 18 how butt plugs
work give me a
I I mean that is something
I'll violate TOS if I keep going on like
you know you know we'll save it for the
members only show which is coming up in
uh you know half an hour but could you
imagine how funny it would be I wouldn't
I will say this I will be in no way
surprised at all if like in one year's
time
Del Mulvaney uploads a video of him
wearing a suit and tie with a deeper
voice saying hey everybody I just want
to let you know the whole thing was a
bit to prove how insane all of you are
I'm a Conservative Christian have been
the whole time and then have them just
be like Han like the idea that you could
increasingly increment the insanity the
insults the degradation and you would
keep supporting it proves the point so
like hilarious you don't see with Dylan
Mulvaney a calm rational person saying
we just want to live like that's the
argument I like to make no don't move
any like does the most shockingly
offensive things possible the most
insulting ways possible thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time